Okay, so we're looking at, the newly added function,
audioRecorderDidFinishRecording, and in here, I want to do two things.
The first thing to do, is to save the recorded audio, and
the next thing I want to do, is to move to the second scene of the app.
AKA perform a segue.
Let's begin with step one, which is to save the recorded audio.
Now, I'm looking to save two things about the recorded audio,
the title of that file and the path where it is stored on the phone.
I'll do that, by creating a new class called RecordedAudio.
By the way, in case you're wondering, this new class.
Will be the model for our app, and that will form the M of the acronym MVC.
Let's create this class next.